les directions à présent pour termine
journal marseille et qui a la réputation
d'être la capitale française du rap le
succès d'iam l'un des grands groupes du
genre a généré l'apparition d'une
multitude de nouveaux rappeur dans la
ville marseille où le langage et fleurie
offre un terrain particulièrement
favorable à ce style musical très
spontané ce qu'est le rap le reportage
de thierry cham fleurs et jean pierre
ryckmans on dit de marseille qu elle
rappe comme elle respire l'identité
marseillaise a toujours été affirmé
ici le verbe peut être d'une redoutable
spontanéité on en marre de faire les
noix de cajou la télé maintenant c'est
court encore maintenant ils sont fiers
de nous mais la réalité n'est pas
toujours aussi souriante plusieurs
groupes phare du rap marseillais sont
issus de ce quartier l'un des plus
déshérités de france le parc bellevue
est surnommé parc mal vu par ses
habitants qui s'affirment victimes de
leur mauvaise réputation
quand il s'agit de trouver du travail ou
déménager dans le quartier n'a pas que
des voyous des les vendeurs de drogues
contraires aux mêmes médias sous déposer
dessus s'écrie c'est dans le mur c'est
la fonky family trois disques d'or en un
an et le souci pour ces jeunes gens de
rester proche des réalités de leur ville
malgré un succès national
on a toujours les mêmes train de vie que
cavani fréquente pour lui même endroit
toujours les mêmes gens qui sont autour
de nous il ya pas grand chose qui a
changé hormis peut-être le regard de
certaines vis-à-vis nous voilà les
bonnes ça il faut faire avec quoi avec
plus de deux millions d'albums vendus la
carrière d'iam fait rêver beaucoup
d'adolescents marseillais une nouvelle
génération qui ne cache pas son désir de
réussite financière
maintenant la jeunesse d'aujourd'hui à
13 ans 14 ans s'est alors pas un minimum
6 ans cet emprunt ne reproche avait pas
cinq ils font connaître au succès il n'y
a pas de suite quoi et pour travailler
patience les membres d'iam ont créé
plusieurs structures de production ce
jour là
cheops assiste au tournage du premier
clip des très prometteur cicad
les chanteurs âgés de 18 et 20 ans à
marseille leur a pas fait officiellement
son entrée dans les écoles ces
adolescents plutôt réticent vis-à-vis de
la scolarité gêne pourtant tous les
mercredis alors qu'ils n'ont pas cours
sous la direction de grand frère rappeur
confirmés ils travaillent leurs textes
et leurs techniques
si on vient d'un quartier défavorisé où
le rap ça permet à pas mal de jeunes
d'acquérir vocabulaire d'acquérir une
connaissance de la langue française
tous ne réussiront pas dans la musique
mais ils ont trouvé ici un moyen
d'expression unique pour raconter leurs
villes leurs quartiers et leurs
aspirations et ça gêne le système
puissiez d'en bas